pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez vous
et activer la petite cloche
attention hein
[Applaudissements]
e
pourquoi fait-on des crêpes à la
chandeleur s'est pas trompé
[Musique]
c'est une fête à la fois païenne et
chrétienne à l'origine il y à la fête
hofland organisée avant le printemps
chez les celtes et chez les romains pour
célébrer le retour de la lumière
après de longs mois d'hiver mais c'est
aussi dans la religion chrétienne le
moment où l'on célèbre un événement
particulier la venue de jésus au temple
de jérusalem pour fêter cet épisode le
pape serge premiers en fonction au
septième siècle décide d'organiser des
processions avec des pèlerins portant
des cierges
la festa candelarum comme il l'appelle
la fête des chandelles chandelle à
l'origine du mot chandler et les crêpes
dans tout ça vous connaissez la recette
pour 300 g de farine 3 lanthier 3
cuillères à soupe de sucre et d'huile 50
g de beurre fondu et 60 santelli de sel
allez une larme d'europe
ce sont des ingrédients à la portée de
tous à l'origine les crêpes étaient
cuisinés par les paysans une façon de
montrer qu'il avait encore de quoi
manger après l'hiver par ailleurs la
forme et la couleur des crèmes évoque le
soleil et donc le retour du printemps
d'après une légende réussir à faire
sauter une crêpe de la main droite en
tenant une pièce d'or de la main gauche
porte bonheur à mon avis avec un euro ça
devrait marcher aussi
[Musique]
ça marche je suis heureux si vous avez
aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser
un pouce bleus merci les épis curieux
pour les plus gourmands en voici l'autre
et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]